the media has been fixated on
disqualifying Donald Trump before a vote
has even been cast but they also want to
frighten off anybody who might be
thinking of working for him like my next
guest Mike Davis a conservative lawyer
and activist with a serious inside track
to a top job under a president Trump 47
at the justice department Mike Davis is
on their radar not in spite of but
almost certainly because of his unhinged
rhetoric one who seems Keen to
transformed Trump's darkest fascist
impulses into an actual policy agenda
the issue isn't right-wing legal
activist on TV host trolling although
the open Fascism and bigotry is pretty
appalling it's the fact that Mike Davis
could actually be Trump's attorney
general in real life so just remember
that
name here now to respond to this smear
campaign is Mike Davis founder and
president of the article 3 project uh
Mike that's quite the compliment these
people scared to death with you where
are year away from the election and
they're already criticizing people that
might work for Donald
Trump yeah it's very flattering I want
to put these goofballs at MSNBC on
article 3 projects board of directors
because they are the best fundraisers
we've ever had at the article 3 project
I troll the left about uh weaponizing
the justice department the Democrats
Biden and his Democrat allies are
actually doing it right they are they've
indicted Trump four crimes unprecedented
indictments for non crimes they've
impeached him twice for nonsense they're
trying to bankrupt his business for nonf
fraud and they've illegally gagged him
twice they're even trying to throw him
off the ballot so they they talk about
they're the Protectors of democracy it
sounds like they're the
fascist yeah they're all for democracy
as long as it's their democracy who
wouldn't want to have an actual vote out
there I want you to listen to this
former FBI official he because he's
freaking out over Trump actually wanting
to clean house at the Department of
Justice have watched this this is a
national security matter for for me and
should be for everybody because it does
pose an existential threat to democracy
they will fire people at at will we
would literally turn doj into a weapon
used by a president against his
enemies I mean is there any more irony
than that I mean these people are
actually saying
this yeah they turned the FBI against
then candidate Donald Trump in 2016 when
they falsely accused him of Russian
collusion they turned the FBI in the
Intel agencies against Donald Trump in
2020 over Hunter Biden's laptop and now
they've turned the FBI and the Biden
justice department against President
Trump his top AIDS uh his supporters on
January 6 parents outreached at school
board meetings Christians uh protesting
outside of abortion clinics while they
give amnesty to their BLM and antifa and
Hamas base along with Joe Biden and his
corrupt
family Mike Davis uh the irony is just
dripping just dripping tonight so Mike
Davis thank you for joining us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else